[Música]
reunimos a siete fanáticos de harry
potter soy fan de harry potter save and
de harry potter soy fan de harry potter
soy fan de harry potter soy fan de harry
potter oi fan de harry potter soy fan de
harry potter uno de ellos es un impostor
si el grupo descubre quién es se
dividirá en un premio en efectivo
[Música]
si el impostor sobrevive y se llevará
todo el premio
es el impostor
lo mejor que podemos hacer ahora es
decir nuestra casa y nuestros patronos
nutria de acuerdo soy deja folk-pop y
una musaraña y folk pop y peta duro de
azúcar raven club alquimia raven club
ardilla roja amor love nutria gryffindor
nutria creo que sospechaba de rachel
ella y yo éramos las únicas vestidas con
el disfraz completo yo esperaba que
todos hicieran lo mismo así que como
nadie lo hizo pensé quién ha leído los
libros o un bien personal cuál es su
libro favorito el tercero y el primer
análisis de fuego el primero si yo diría
el 7 cristian era de estaban la orden
del fénix' el príncipe mestizo' bien si
realmente sospechaba de cameron no
llevaba ropa deja fútbol real no hablaba
tanto así que pensé que se sentía
abrumado por la cantidad de información
de la que hablábamos cuál fue el hechizo
que lanzó her maggioni en el segundo
libro cuando arregló las gafas de harry
o culos reparo sí en que el libro
dijiste es el segundo cuando están en el
callejón de turn out no es en el segundo
libro así es yo estaba como y yo como
así que me puse un poco a la defensiva
cuáles son los colores reales de su casa
los bronce cuando tienes siete personas
un minuto no es suficiente todo iba muy
rápido por lo que era difícil descartar
quién podría ser
[Música]
sospechaba mucho de cameron porque no
hablaba en absoluto
[Música]
yo le hubiera sacado a mí mismo siento
que tome un respiro y luego me fui
cuando empezaron a leer harry potter el
primer libro en el momento en que sea
así que estaba en quinto grado de hecho
mi mamá lo leyó para mi clase no leí los
libros hasta hace siete años porque nací
y crecí en el salvador y ella era
demasiado costoso para mí conseguirlos
pero con mi primer salario compré mi
primer libro de harry potter que fue el
primero mi hermana era fanática de harry
potter pero me asusté cuando vi a
voldemort y me pregunte es una película
de terror en la secundaria ya estaba muy
muy enamorada de este chico y él era un
gran fanático así que realmente quería
impresionar lo entonces comencé a leer
todos los libros y vi todas las
películas knicks y estás viendo esto
apaga el vídeo no me dejaban leerlos
cuando era niña mis padres decían no
queremos que te conviertas en una bruja
y yo pero vaya es falso a fútbol si
tienen su jefe de casa es la profesora
sports pregunta para los ravens close
cuál es su verdadera mascota es un
águila sí para los ravens close quien es
nuestro jefe de te refieres al fundador
al fundador robin ahora debemos
interrogar a la chica
aquí va porque era conocido batman él
era el locutor
en la copa mundial
yo estaba como me equivoqué le hice una
pregunta sobre el luto para cual un
personaje de los libros que no llegó a
las películas quería ver si realmente
había leído los libros en lugar de ver
las películas o haberse estudiado todo
mi corazón late con fuerza ahora siento
que lo tanto fan fiction que estoy como
mis fans estoy como que debería de algo
atraído aislamiento si puesto
aislamientos son fan fiction sobre un
incipiente romance ante draco y germán y
sí por supuesto que lo leí es un clásico
tengo una pregunta para ti
porque no trajiste además de tu varita
ninguna otra primero porque la ropa
temática de harry potter es muy costosa
no use nada de mercancía relacionada
probablemente eso le dio a mucha gente
motivos para sospechar de mí su camiseta
era de cómics el intruso seguramente
tendrá una varita pero qué pasa con el
resto de la ropa cuál es su parte
favorita de los libros que no apareció
en las películas
si todos han leído los libros deberían
poder nombrar alguna parte que no estuvo
en las películas la mía es cuando
voldemort muere porque en las películas
muere como desintegrado y muere como un
hombre mortal cuando roger mahony
también mal fue y se vuelven perfectos y
luego están caminando por la escuela
germán y dice harry no andes provocando
a mal fue y ahora es perfecto y puede
hacerte la vida difícil y él dice vaya
me pregunto qué sería una vida difícil
creo que sería la final del quid y en el
prisionero de azkaban solo porque eso no
estuvo en la película de acuerdo
desearía que hubieran incluido a pits el
poltergeist durante todas las películas
él nunca estuvo allí chicos les agrada
snape algún fan de snape sí no odio sne
pidió a petunia literalmente la golpeó
con una rama y fue entonces cuando
mostró en nada en ninguno de los libros
ni en ninguna de las películas que
demuestre que en realidad no le agrada
ser así tanto en los libros como en las
películas siento que todo el tiempo
tiene el apoyo de don't bother no sé no
me ha agradado mucho es un manipulador
no me agrada es raro ayer hablaba
demasiado probablemente sólo está
diciendo todos los datos que estudió y
hablando de más para que el resto no
pueda hablar
el manipulador el cielo es literalmente
miro a cada personaje como si fuera una
persona real y el trasfondo de don
bulldog como lo que sucedió con green
del world siento que lo hace más humano
y puedo relacionarme con él lo siento
[Música]
tenemos un empate el empate es entre
kylie e in song
eso significa que vamos a desempatar así
que cada uno de ustedes tendrá 20
segundos para convencerlos creo que
todos aquí sabrían la cita al final del
libro cuando pips sale al pasillo y dice
algo como los hemos machacado menudo
sujeto es potter y ahora a divertirse
que volví estiró la pata
volví estiro la paz la verdad soy una
patética tardía pero me encanta harry
potter estas zonas sitios importantes
como en el mercado lindan hat end black
part y el funk house y pasé mucho tiempo
allí o dios mío y también he estado en
el mundo de harry potter obviamente soy
una patética verdadera y estoy muy
nerviosa y creo que por eso estoy tan
callada y bloqueada pero
[Música]
buena suerte bingos perdón
esta será la ronda de sus escenas
favoritas de las películas cada uno de
ustedes podrá decirle a los demás cuál
es su escena favorita y por qué mi
película favorita es la tercera pero mi
escena favorita es de la sexta cuando
harry bebe el félix félix y la suerte
líquida y él simplemente camina por allí
y cuando encuentra el profesor slughorn
y él le dice harry y él responde señor
cuando están en el comedor y cada uno
está comiendo en las mesas de sus casas
y carl y empieza a coquetear con la
chica que le gustaba la cual olvide su
nombre y él dice quiero agua para esto
miraré la botella de agua y entonces
derrama toda el agua porque está muy
nervioso mientras coquetea con ella la
primera la ruina por completo pero dije
está bien tengo un respaldo y tengo otra
cuando harry le dado vi el libro con el
calcetín y dovi dice el amo le ha dado
bien calcetín en la orden del fénix' la
pelea entre don bol d'or y voldemort es
una locura es la única razón por la que
de verdad me gustan las películas me
dieron una forma de ver lo que había
estado leyendo desde los 10 años cuando
en un recuerdo se ve james potter
intimidando us navy se le bajara los
pantalones a ese nivel y es un es en
importante para mí porque aunque sea
admirable tiene defectos como todos los
personajes en las reliquias de la muerte
cuando germán y lanza el ovv libia de
sus padres es muy triste pero es algo
muy gryffindor de ella proteger a sus
padres haciéndolos olvidarla ni siquiera
sabe si podrá recuperar sus memorias
creo que la persona más sospechosa fue
grecia porque se quedó en blanco con un
par de cosas
[Música]
no soy la impostora
me siento tan mal me decepcione y mucho
hice mi mejor esfuerzo para venir con un
uniforme completo quizás el impostor se
sintió amenazado y por eso me sacaron no
lo sé si desean seguir jugando levanten
la mano en
votaremos una vez más en
hayley mencionó que su hermana era gran
fan de harry potter así que podría estar
usando la sudadera y la varita de su
hermana empecé a dudar de bryant él
podría ser la opción menos probable pero
también la mayor sorpresa haré una
última votación y eso es todo 3 2 1
creo que nunca hemos tenido una
situación acción ya puedo decir somos
mágicos luego de 10 minutos decidimos
permitirle a cada uno explicar por qué
querían continuar o terminar el juego
uno de ustedes podría ser el impostor
que quiere que termine el juego para
llevarse todo el dinero creo que no hay
nada de malo en tener otra ronda yo
siento que lo atrapamos ustedes tres han
tenido argumentos bastante profundos el
nivel de información del que hemos
estado hablando es muy intenso y creo
que el impostor no podría saber tales
cosas quiero seguir porque tengo muchas
sospechas y una gran parte de mí me está
diciendo
necesito ser uno de los
últimos supervivientes la verdad ya no
sé qué hacer vayamos por una última
ronda de votaciones si desean seguir
jugando levanten la mano en
321 sea bien se terminó más vale
que hayamos acertado 3 lanzaré un cruce
entonces si las luces se ponen verdes
ustedes ganaron si las luces se ponen
rojas el impostor todavía está en la
caca y ustedes perdieron
[Música]
y cuando se puso verde pensé genial lo
logramos me emocioné estoy muy contenta
de haber llegado al final y muy
orgullosa de mí misma lo siento kylie
vote por ti varias veces sustentando un
mundo del día ahora me siento mal
obviamente los pensamos en ti porque
sabías mucho yo estaba como el impostor
me va a enloquecer puede el impostor por
favor dar un paso adelante y revelarse
en 3 2 1
[Música]
lo siento mucho si soy yo si soy yo por
por hice la prueba pero mi compañero de
habitación es un gran fanático quedé
traumatizada con el rostro de voldemort
cuando tenía seis años subí la primera
película por eso nunca más volví
teniendo en cuenta que nunca he leído
ninguno de los libros de harry potter y
sólo he visto unas dos películas creo
que hice un buen trabajo no me gusta
harry potter y nunca me gustará ya puedo
escuchar a los odiosos detrás de la
pantalla entonces no leíste historia
sobre eso
me siento tan traicionada fue muy bueno
que estudiara así que hayas traído un
suéter te esfuerzas
decir que lo hice mejor yo hasta aquí
[Música]